to come in the game will Magnus be on
top I Want To Praise kokesh though he
looks so focused and we're off it's a
King's Pawn opening Magnus does he know
that he starts the game with seven
minutes he's just adjusting his pieces
losing valuable seconds here and he
eventually plays E5
what will we see earlier we saw a
Italian game and it's a repeat of the
classical game the classical clash
between these two Magnus happy with his
opening there seemingly Judah are you
surprised to see Magnus repeat we
thought he was in trouble a bit uh
earlier on in the classical well I think
the travels he had
he he did not consider necessarily that
it was so serious and probably he
discovered how he is going to be
deviating
in this position
okay and Magnus has deviated indeed he's
pushed his Pawn to A6 and dropped back
with his dark squared bishop and this is
where surely the importance of having
seconds on site to do the homework to do
the preparation uh is invaluable it's
priceless
clearly Magnus has had someone helping
him and uh he's gone to check this
opening and okay finally black castles
is very different from earlier though
well at this point for example in this
tournament I think it is very important
for the players to have a second because
for sure the seconds are going to be
taking a look already during the game
what kind of ideas they have for the
Armageddon if they get that point and of
course Magnus has his second over here
so that that is a lot of help I think
mentally also that you get an advice and
then you're on your own but still you
have someone who checked it and gives
the proper advice
yeah and I was getting flashbacks and I
was thinking I've seen this position
before and of course it's very similar
to one of magnus's games against Wesley
so
yeah the problem with the Italian game
is I always get flashbacks I always get
deja vu and then it turns out it's not
this exact position I've seen before
it's just something that looks almost
identical
and also it's uh also pretty okay I
think that he's repeating the same line
because it was very difficult for Magnus
to create something that he can play for
a win right but at this point the draw
and the Victory is the same amount of
point he can gain so usually I don't
think he's worried too much that he
should be losing any of the game
yeah when Magnus needs to be solid he
tends to thrive uh that is yeah going
back to basics for him and we see a
night trade set of Pawns have left the
board as well
I thought the black will be going to d8
but of course as draw is enough
and maybe this is possible because after
Rook B5 black would be going probably
just rook fb8 and C6 would be
unavoidable
so basically Magnus just wants to
simplify the position make it easy
draw the game
yeah he looks a massive favorite to do
that I think kokesh is Mr trick here I
think he just assumed he could take the
spawn because
the other option is just to trade the
Rooks off and black has no problems at
all there if anyone's better it's going
to be black with the open file if you
take this Rook now the question is uh I
have a crazy idea it can white go Rook
B5 Rook fb8 D4 and then on C6 somehow D
takes E5 Rook E5 sacrificing giving up
an exchange with interesting
circumstances Wow Let's jump in this
could be a potentially key moment if
gukesh doesn't get ambitious doesn't
gamble right now he might never get a
chance in this Armageddon root takes B5
Judith
and he's taken and he's taken we're
expecting Rook here threatening a
discovered attack Bishop takes F2 check
is a threat winning the white Rook next
move so you want to block The Bishop's
threat and after C6 something on E5
either Pawn takes or Rook takes what
Magnus played G5 instead first and after
Bishop G3
probably he will be playing Knight D7
that maybe Knight D7 can be strong
E7 threatening to trap this rook and
also defending the E5 Pawn
this looks strong this white Rook now
trapped and this happened on the board
I go cash striking out in the center now
look at this
D4 on the board he's going to give up
the exchange after point of C6 he's
going to sacrifice here and take this
Pawn in the center he's got two pawns
for the exchange here but look at this
what happens he went F6 and now D5 is
possible or taking on E5 could be in D5
so The Rook maybe will save itself
but uh kakash decides to actually trade
Pawns in the middle
and it does look like The Rook is going
to be saved
but it has come at the cost of white
locking in their own Bishop
this one looks like great compensation
for black as well you mentioned it
Ivanka this bishop locked in for white
this Rook potentially locked in even if
it doesn't get trapped even if it
doesn't fall off the board it's not
necessarily greatly placed and yeah
anything could still happen in this
position Magnus picking up the pace only
a minute down now I think rule D5 should
be the move to save The Rook for the
moment
I was also one yeah I agree with you but
I also wondered about C4 C5 if you're in
a must win situation yeah I was also
wondering of C4 and after C6 you would
be capturing the bishop I guess thanks
and C5 and this is what we see on the
board you're a prophet Ivanka is
happening kukesh needs to gamble and
he's ready to give up material in order
to do so I thought it's not going to be
enough for him
but I understand that he's going to this
direction
so good C4 that shows zero fear at all
we were talking about that earlier the
benefit of being a young player you
believe in all of your calculations you
never doubt you never think about what
could go wrong and Magnus looking away
maybe frustrated that his young opponent
is going straight for him
not backing down
C5 is imminent breaking this black pawn
chain if this Pawn chain falls apart
White's minor Pieces come in I have also
a little Deja Vu like when Magnus played
against Wesley so the Armageddon on it
so somehow a little similar that the
Magnus had in not such a good position
and then he was flashing out some very
interesting moves with material down and
he was making Magic
uh I'm not sure who's trying to work the
magic here kukesh has given up his Rook
for Black's bishop and wow Magnus body
language does not look positive
suddenly White's won a second Pawn level
material who's better here and why he's
not exactly the most happy I guess
Magnus but I don't see what is really
wrong with his position
26 Rook D1 I mean there is a certain
Harmony to Black's position and whereas
white will be always pressured by the
thought that his Bishop on G3 is just
trapped
oh and question mark four magnus's last
move it looks like the evaluation E5 can
be captured I was
Knight takes Pawn is possible here yeah
Bishop takes or Knight takes I'm not
sure Bishop takes there might have been
Rook takes F3 so Knight takes on the
board this utilizes the fact that wow
missed opportunity according to the
computer but this looks clever if
everything is captured then later on
there would have been a nasty Queen
check on C4 Magnus instantly reacts with
Rook to A2
was this a trap has he tricked kokesh
well Queen C4 is still possible having a
lot of pawns for white three pawns for
an exchange
yeah but there's something happening on
F2 we had Maurice whoa kukashi's giving
up his Queen
whoa wow
or maybe very uncomfortable position for
black wow what a game Knight C5 E5 E6
brilliant played by the youngster this
Pawn is running both of white spawns are
running
this is scary for Magnus Black's Queen
alone cannot fight the whole white Army
Magnus needs something
if I sing a queen
for a bishop and a knight
unbelievable I don't think it would have
even entered my radar and what happened
with this G3 bad Bishop right it's just
protecting the amazing D6 boss spawn
supporting this Pawn defending F2 this
Bishop's holding everything together for
white and bang bang just two more moves
if white gets the pawn to E6 it's game
over very frustrating and very difficult
position to play it with black
I guess Magnus is going to be pinning
his hopes on establishing a blockade on
the light squares and
What's Happening Now threatening the
white Rook there are back rank problems
for gokesh right now he needs to take a
timeout maybe improve the white Rook Hey
one
okay F3 what a nice move protecting it
with the bishop
why is Bishop doing all of the work in
this game
and what can Magnus do now the black
Rook is stuck there are all sorts of
threats White's e-pawn in some cases can
advance at the same time I'm not sure
about this F3 with Rook a true K2 there
is a Target on G2
as a counter attack counter play
potentially it takes a while though does
black have that time the white pawns
look so scary white is threatening in
some lights just drop the White Knight
back as well gain time against that
black queen and then the pawns will roll
what again
I do like that comment we need more
games like this I wholeheartedly agree I
mean fire on the board Magnus now
ticking close to two minutes on the
clock whereas figure cash five minutes
and Magnus grabbing the pawn it's a big
question for good cash can he push the
e-pawn to its destination what a game
I think you have to take your time out
maybe move that white knight out the way
first but either way not just the speed
with which he's playing just the way
he's kind of moves to the pieces kukesh
he reminds me of a young Anand from the
videos I've seen just yeah
winning move E6 giving up the Knight and
the E7 and then the black Rook moves
the problem is ah these uh what where do
you move D7 let's see then D7 and then
there's a queen
so white cannot push yet wow H3 I like
that I I had this in mind King to H2 no
rush
no need to rush and Magnus is going for
your plan Judah he needs counterplay
that's the only way to do it right
I would go Knight G4 somehow so to
try to push E6 though after that King E6
comes already
white can go wrong easily
both sides can go wrong Magnus under two
minutes but he gains increment in seven
moves time the White Knight needs to get
out of the way for the pawns to roll
it's a race I don't believe that Magnus
can create enough counter player if
white is accurate but how to be accurate
with only a few minutes on your clock so
many tempting moves
why tonight has to retreat surely that
looks like step one yeah but the
question is where because wherever you
are going to be retreating here night
King E6 will be positioning itself maybe
Knight E4 with the idea of Bishop F2 and
Knight C5
but I also understand this decision to
play D7 because he's very much afraid
that Rook A2 is
coming
time to give a check to the king
centralize the queen
yeah the black queens can centralize you
can maybe make an argument for
blockading with the black king as well
lots of options here for Magnus
one and a half minutes now though
such a hard position to defend
extremely dangerous follows your advice
Ivanka that's a check
Queen's the best in the center of the
board
yeah we'll wipe drop the bishop back to
block or just hide his King he hides the
king
okay and and big question is
are the pawns racing down that's why the
king steps forward and blockades the
pawn and Magnus down on time
just over one minute left and the
position is so wild but right now it
seems like black stabilized a little bit
because the bishop cannot move didn't
because of the E5 might be under attack
and anyway that it doesn't have a space
the Knight cannot move now which is very
important because the D7 Pawn is under
attack so it's not so easy for white to
continue
Rook C1 maybe to attack it's very
difficult to make the right move I
believe
Magnus taking a sip of his water there
I'm getting flashbacks as well when
kukesh beat Magnus in the Norway chess
Blitz just a few days ago that was also
a crazy material imbalance that was a
queen for Knight and two pawns and uh
here it's like Queen for Bishop Knight
and two pawns it's uh crazy how that
game is being mirrored right now and
okay indecision there hesitation from
kukesh what's he gonna do it feels like
he's going to move his Rook
where to put that piece is he going to
go attack that black queen is he going
to slide The Rook to C1 as you drew
didn't mentioned there
I like the comments in the future chat
kukesh is in tile mode
but tar finishes things off that's the
difference how is gokesh gonna finish
this game
he needs to get that win remember a draw
not sufficient Rook C1 met calmly by C5
Black's got this past Pawn as well some
source of counter play Rook B1 trying to
get to B6
yeah and then the black pawn will roll
so complicated
pressure is on and cash now ticking to
under one minute and 40 seconds
um is the time
to kind of step back with the Knight and
pin all hopes on the E Pawn because
White's Rook is just not joining in the
action he does indeed step back with the
Knight but now the d-pawn drops you feel
that that was White's pride and joy
really but maybe he needed to be done
I like actually this move from the
perspective that Bishop Bishop 2 after
Rook C5 will be very strong but of
course it's a shame that the depot D7
Plus Pawn is gone oh and Magnus not
actually capturing the phone oh he means
business and instead pushing the pawn to
C4 wow
C2 then Rook A1 right
The Rook slides up then black can
actually get back uh down behind on
White's first rank with Rook A1 and
queen G1 ideas okay Knight D6 he's
jumping in can Magnus keep his Pawn
alive or is it time finally to capture
that scary white d-pawn look at kakash
look kind of taking that Peak up at the
screen now he's getting one second
increment in a few moves time
both players under the one minute mark
no way back from here it's going to be
Eternal time travel I think I'll just
take that pawn too scary I know Magnus
is in a confident mood I think he's
going to push the pawn on C3
then I'd be five oh you're right
and no it comes back
oh maybe that pawns life was short-lived
after all
and rule this race rathering big threat
Magnus has to move his King okay one
with a blunder
what is he oh okay I thought he was
going to put his King on a bad Square
there if he Retreats out of the way of
any night checks C6 very powerful
still threats on the board Magnus moving
his Queen away
and black is on the verge of going on a
counter-attack but whoa the evaluation
bar leaps up there is now a win for
gakesh apparently E6 is a winning move
right now pushing the white pawn and
black and Bishop B5 yeah Black's King is
caught in the crossfire oh that would
have been amazing net but he misses it
go cash
black queen comes back now but he's
still putting the pressure on still
threats Rook D2 threaten now penny that
black queen to its king
and Magnus less than 10 seconds less
than five seconds oh
getting a one second increment that is
nothing
I feel that maybe that was the one
moment that good cash could have cashed
in and suddenly he's repeating with this
bishop the black wriggling behind
counterplay the white king not safe you
see the relief of Magnus look at the
body language oh for a momentum I'm in
safety but he only has three seconds
left on the clock well I only gets a one
second increment but on the board on the
board
well there's not just the board though
they should check but now the other
white porn has disappeared all of
White's winning chances are falling with
the fall of his pawns and okay a bunch
of quick moves
wow blunder tonight on E6